scusate io sono abituato a stare sul
palco dove si suona quindi buonasera e
tutti ieri
grazie
e sono più abituato a suonare che a
parlare quindi spero di non fare danni
troppo grossi comunque sono qua per
rispondere se riuscirò a una domanda che
tutti gli artisti si fanno nella vita
qual è il percorso che un musicista deve
fare per trovare la sua personalità
artistica
qualunque sia il genere musicale
ci sono delle tappe del tappe
obbligatorie dove il musicista deve
passare per forza
queste tappe possono anche diventare
degli scogli dove l'artista si può
allenare e fermarsi io li ho divisi in
tre fasi fondamentali la prima è la fase
del mito quella dove un musicista arriva
ad un certo punto della sua vita dove ha
imparato la musica imparato lo strumento
e si crea un mito non so il mito di
frank zappa il mito
di miles davis si crea un mito che
solitamente corrisponde allo strumento
che suona un mito che lui comincia a
farlo diventare un dio a copiarlo in
tutto per tutto a copiare le sue frasi
musicali a suonare il suo repertorio a
vestirsi come lui magari se potesse
anche ad avere la sua stessa fidanzata
ecco diciamo che questa fase è molto
pericolosa perché oltre
a rischiare di essere un clone di un
qualcosa che già esiste il musicista
piano piano si intristisce
perché capisce andando avanti con il
tempo che questa è una meta
irraggiungibile
la seconda fase che arriva subito dopo è
la ricerca di se stessi una serie di
domande che sono ma avrò fatto bene a
fare il musicista
farò bene a suonare il susa phone chi me
l'ha fatto fare ogni volta che scendo
dalla macchina e lo devo trasportare
penso chi me l'ha fatto fare di una
persona toe il flauto me lo diceva mio
papà di suonare il clarinetto
ecco le domande sono tante
certe domande anche quando uno si trova
bene all'interno di un genere musicale
non so sto suonando il liscio
faccio tanti soldi
questo è il mio genere ideale
ecco c'è il rischio anche qua di non
capire mai quale sarà il nostro vero
indirizzo musicale nostra vera
attitudine e di non interessarsi a tutto
quello che in realtà è la musica che è
un mondo vastissimo
ecco che solo una parte arriva alla
terza fase che per me è una fase di
arrivo e di iniziazione la fase
chiamiamo la open in questa fase i
musicisti sono aperti a tutto quello che
è la musica dal jazz la musica
improvvisata la musica classica e la
musica contemporanea ricordo la prima
volta che ascolta il concerto per
trombone solo non posso dire di quale
artista che era fatto così
dopo venti minuti mio amico mi diceva
aspetta aspetta che adesso succede
qualcosa di interessante
dico in realtà la finale fu brava
che bella questa cosa cioè valeva la
pena forse di ascoltare fino alla fine
ma se non l'avesse ascoltato non lo
saprei dire direi che insomma
l'interesse la cosa principale no avere
un interesse essere curiosi la curiosità
di guardarsi attorno senza trascurare il
fatto che con il tempo
guardando tutte queste cose meno male
una persona crea un suo bagaglio di
esperienze che andando avanti con il
tempo saranno fondamentali per creare la
propria personalità tutte queste
esperienze questi e col colori
queste cose che abbiamo avuto modo di
incontrare di suonare e di vivere di
leggere di guardare in un film di
relazionarsi con una persona saranno
sicuramente fondamentali per arrivare
alla nostra forma d'arte e ben precisa
ecco allora arrivò alla mia forma d'arte
quella che ho inventato io che l'ho
inventata per me stesso naturalmente
giusto per farmi coraggio dire da che ci
sei quasi sì perché l'importante non è
poi quello di arrivare a fare veramente
un qualcosa di importante ma è comunque
crederci continuamente che prima o dopo
ci si arriva ecco se c'è questa speranza
forse c'è anche la speranza che un buon
10 per cento ci arriverà detto questo
quello che ho inventato io e la musica
susa fonica oppure susa fonia e una
musica che suonata da un gruppo che si
chiama susa follis che attualmente
elabora questa musica era realizzato
sotto forma di cd cartoni animati
musica per video
artistici e quant'altro la parola susa
fonia contiene due parole fondamentali
la parola susa fo e la parola sinfonia
il suo fan come vedete è questo
strumento molto strano che io ho portato
qua oggi è uno strumento pensate un po
l'unico strumento che è stato inventato
per far sì che la musica si potesse
muovere naturalmente il significato che
io do a questo movimento e metaforico il
movimento potrebbe essere quello
all'interno di una struttura musicale ma
allo stesso tempo potrebbe essere quello
per piazza avrà quello in canada in new
york negli stati uniti nella foresta
nera un movimento che attraversa
l'oceano atlantico
allo stesso tempo dalla parola sinfonia
tiriamo fuori altri due parole
fondamentali che sono suonare insieme
tutta la nostra musica è fondata su
questo principio il principio di
collettivo musicale
il collettivo musicale lo troviamo già
nelle forme di musica popolare ma non
solo nella musica
jazz tradizionale e guardate caso anche
nella musica gestri della musica libera
la il collettivo musicale non è altro
che una serie di musicisti che
improvvisano simultaneamente insieme
nello stesso momento e uno dice ecco
perché quando ascolto quella musica la
sento un casino che non si capisce
niente ecco in realtà succede anche
questo ma gran parte delle volte questo
sono insieme si è fatto con il giusto
interplay e giusto fini e i musicisti
sono all'altezza della situazione può
portare a creare una
serie di
contrappunti e armonia casuali che al
momento nascono insieme si sviluppano e
creano una composizione istantanea
questa fase veramente straordinaria e
noi quest oggi faremo sentire qualche
piccolo esempio iniziando da questo
brano che vi suoneremo adesso che per
essere susa fonico ha bisogno che voi
pensiate che noi in questo momento siamo
proiettati all'interno di un film di
buster keaton
se ascoltiamo un vecchio disco degli
anni cinquanta sentiremo insieme alla
musica un fruscio
mentre se ascoltiamo la registrazione
attuale questo flusso io non lo sentiamo
più ma in quella musica il fruscio fa
parte della musica stessa
il mondo che ci circonda è fatto di
suoni rumori che spesso siamo abituati a
mente abituati ad ascoltare che non ci
facciamo nemmeno caso mi vengono in
mente degli amici che abitano vicino
all'aeroporto di villafranca e ci hanno
questi aerei che gli passano sopra le
case o
ormai per loro è una cosa normale questi
rumori e questi suoni anche i suoni
degli elettrodomestici di casa della
televisione che va inutilmente di queste
voci che ci continuano a circondare
tutte queste cose ormai fanno parte di
un paesaggio sonoro che è in continua
evoluzione e in continuo cambiamento
gli stessi giocattoli dei bambini nei
nostri figli suonano hanno dei rumori
delle cose incredibili
quindi tutte queste questi suoni che
oggi giorno sentiamo i suoni vecchi
suoni ultramoderni fanno parte di un
qualcosa che esiste realmente e che noi
potremo utilizzare per comporre questa
cosa non l'ho inventata io ma la legge
parecchio tempo fa sul morale di armonia
di un grandissimo compositore chamber
che disse che il futuro della musica
sarà proprio questo lavorare sui timbri
cercando di comporre come di timbri non
più con le note musicali
a tal proposito vorrei farvi sentire un
esempio fatto dal nostro caro grandioso
vincenzo vasi che ci suonerà
non ho fatto con tutti i giocattoli dei
bambini
friedrich
alcuni musicisti hanno cercato di
approfondire la loro gamma espressiva
ricercando proprio di cambiare il timbro
in qualche modo di
scombinare un po il timbro del proprio
strumento o addirittura della propria
voce basti pensare al grandissimo
cantante demetrio stratos
ora io
credo che addirittura prendere una frase
e trasportarla in diverse lingue già
cambia il suono di quello che è la voce
e vi faremo un esempio proprio di questo
grazie alla voce della nostra cantante
vanessa tagliabue yorke
la vita ho temuto
l'amore
russo arabo francese
anche io con il mio trombone usando
qualche artificio
solo a cambiare ea darvi delle
sensazioni molto particolari usando
delle sardine e delle cose molto strane
che addirittura non avete mai visto
sabato
si no
ciao
come se una cosa diretta
bene
nel 2014
evitare di mettere la musica e di
selezionarle in capitoli e sottocapitoli
sarà forse la cosa più importante in
quanto la vera musica sarà quella
fatta col più grande numero di
contaminazioni ricordiamoci che
la tutti gli oggetti che ci circondano
possono creare dei suoni e possono
essere utilizzati per comporre e questo
sarà anche la grandezza dei nuovi
compositori che verranno e non
esisteranno più forme musicali e di così
così settoriali a tal proposito per
dimostrarvi quanto sia semplice con
qualsiasi mezzo fare musica
io vi saluto con questo brano fatto dal
quartetto più conchiglie dei mari delle
antille
grazie vanessa tagliabue
enrico terragnoli vincenzo vasi
grazie sono mauro tutto di ringraziati